[Applause]
and since it's
week we're going big we've got this
fabulous money booth here for one
special audience member to step into and
grab all the cash they can and we'll
also put a special ticket in there ross
tell us about it
there's a gold ticket if they grab that
they win a grand prize and if they grab
the silver ticket the entire audience
will go home with a special prize
okay good all right
that's good news roxy you always deliver
the good news all right where is caitlin
o'shea
[Music]
[Applause]
your moxie and attitude make me feel
like you are
the animal that needs to get in that
booth and go for it yeah
we're twinning by the way look at that i
know that's right
we're tripleting are we
trouble well we try
um okay caitlyn you're going to get 10
seconds in that booth for every single
question that you get right
have you been paying attention of course
i have oh god okay because i'm really
nervous i really want to know
i'm excited for that all right
here we go first question all right for
10 seconds in the booth okay
caitlin what time does madonna go to bed
4 a.m
[Applause]
i'm sorry i get excited
all right these questions get harder
question number two
who was anderson cooper's mother
a vanderbilt
we need a first name gloria vanderbilt
[Applause]
final question what upcoming event are
we celebrating with carbs all week long
the new york city marathon
[Applause]
okay
you stuff that money in every little
place that you can
all right okay i'm gonna put these ones
in right yep
[Applause]
[Applause]
three two
one
oh my god that was so exciting
all right kayla and caitlin are you
ready to find out how much money you won
yeah
by the way that didn't look easy no
but it was fun
what is the amount look
holy cow 1511.
[Applause]
that was not easy you should try it
would be fun i want to see it i just
want to see other people in here
so much so ross do we have something
else well listen you've got over 1500
you grabbed but you did grab something
else what did i grab
if you have the silver bill the audience
gets a prize
[Applause]
go portable rechargeable record player
from victrola
[Applause]
[Applause]
congratulations thank you so much
everybody for choosing to spend your
time with us we make this show for you
so take this good energy with you and
we'll see you again tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
you